do you see that company that
josh richards
his vc firm animal capital is investing
in no it's called colossal
uh this actually sounds familiar they're
they're trying to bring back the woolly
mammoth
sick it is [ __ ] sick that's crazy is
that not sick no it's it makes me laugh
more because in my new set i started
like writing this bit about reanimation
okay like how that's on the way so like
to know that that [ __ ] exists
is awesome reanimation basically the
idea like
could you imagine if
just like this
you know they just start digging people
back up and they're like we can bring
them back oh yeah
yeah this one though they're genetically
modifying uh living species of elephant
okay to withstand super cold
temperatures
and then
i guess the idea is that
um
when these were alive it's like not as
much methane was being released from the
ice because
it doesn't melt as fast because they're
killing something that melts the ice
something like i don't know
some [ __ ] you know ecosystem type
[ __ ] i don't know i'm not a scientist
this is what it's come to to save the
environment yeah no one will buy the
four hundred thousand dollar golf carts
and they will not let go of their chevys
yeah let's bring back the wooly yeah my
whole thing though my whole thought on
this was if you're gonna genetically
modify it and bring it back
why not give it the head of like a
penguin
shark
logan paul we're making the
for real
i was gonna say this is gonna replace uh
french bulldogs
[Laughter]
influencers are going to be running to
get a piece of this and be like yeah me
and my woolly mammoth
melrose on a leash
just stomping on cars and [ __ ] yeah just
just like
in the middle of the crowd at coachella
[Laughter]
killing hundreds of people
okay i i don't like impeding on the
grove
just in front of the apple store with
their [ __ ] woolly mammoth
so when's the first one gonna touch down
is there like a waiting list
is it like a supreme drop like can you
like
can you like get in and get one of them
or uh they're just trying to do one
i think they're just trying to make one
right now it said within five years they
said they're going to try and i mean
it's such it's so cool is it not
no this is some jurassic park [ __ ] yeah
that's all that's left to like
make all of the move the great movies we
know and make them for real you know
yeah what if we were just like [ __ ]
leave them in the ground dude you know
you're tarnishing their legacy
stop bringing [ __ ] back stop remaking it
shitty sequels dude it's dead
we knew about the woolly mammoth it's
over
dude make a new one give the [ __ ]
make a liger bringing back the woolly
mammoth but this time starring josh
richards
which is basically what that is yeah
society society's gonna reset and we're
gonna be sent back into the ice age
and as a society we're gonna have to
vote who carries on our legacy
that's what it's gonna be
everyone's gonna have to campaign as to
why they should be one of the 200 that
are frozen
to restart humanity and josh is in the
front running well i mean he invested in
this guy he did invest in the woolly
mammoth i mean he kind of kind of
deserves to be here man you got
so that's what we need to do that's why
we're cloning them that's very true why
yeah that when all this [ __ ] goes to
hell down there if they don't make it we
still have one exactly to dance for us
come on do the woe
get that old josh up here
come on buddy do a dance do something
[ __ ] woolly mammoths everywhere yeah
there's like a hundred woolly mammoths
that that becomes our new god this
experiment goes horribly wrong no it's
just they make ten thousand of them our
new gopher yeah or like squirrel or
whatever yeah just they're just [ __ ]
everywhere yeah everyone worships the
mammoths they don't you know utmost
respect for the mammoths it's like mommy
daddy where did the mammoths come from
well that's why we believe in josh
johns becomes the new jesus yeah
the leader of the mammoth yeah leader of
the mammoth world
josh richardson
with like a gigantic stick yeah like
[ __ ]
uh gandalf yeah you mean
josh richards arkandilf
mommy who's that leading the mammoth
that's ganda that's gandalf a hundred
mammoths behind him
he's walking through the snow
josh still skinny as [ __ ]
[Laughter]
this way yeah
[Laughter]
i was kind of thinking it'd be funny if
the mammoths were like pests like if
they just over they just [ __ ] it up
and they just started [ __ ] like crazy
and just reproducing like rabbits so
they're just everywhere so there's a
sitcom about mammoth removal and yeah
they're just everywhere people are like
pushing them over get the [ __ ] out of
here
if you look at josh richards like josh
richards
the mammoth whisperer yeah the man
whisperer if you look at gandalf five
years ago fixing his hair to pitch down
avril lavigne sample mashed up with
ceelo crazy yeah to know that he was
gonna invest
through a vc company
and
recreating the woolly mammoth
what the [ __ ] dude
what is going on yeah that is the
simulation theory right there i mean
there's no
you know that's that's a as good of a
piece of evidence as we have yeah it
really is
we should just
end it
kill ourselves
not like that oh what do you mean you
should just blow the ship up oh yeah
okay you know there's nothing left for
us down there yeah and it's not gonna
get any better so well what could what
could we bring back because
like you know for every uber there's a
lift yeah you know every tick tock
there's a triller she's all that there's
all that oh we can bring that back to
dingo go
dingo will be kind of amelia earhart
okay we should find her plane okay and
bring it back okay be like we had you
know
this great plane was lost in the bermuda
triangle so we're bringing it back so we
can all re that's kind of [ __ ] up
rest in peace um what could we bring
back i meant species-wise
okay what's something cool that's
extinct it's not a dinosaur yeah what is
this
just the dodo bird oh dodo bird that's a
good one yeah that's a good one
these little [ __ ] what if we bring
back like a niche
microbe just something kind of [ __ ]
lame yeah like a cell like just a like a
deep sea fish like one that you never
even see i think even smaller it's just
like uh yeah are you talking like a you
know like a pre-shrimp
yeah it's just like a underwater worm
that feeds off of [ __ ] fish poop
it's blind like it can't yeah it just
works off a weird scent yeah we're like
no one knows about these species but
they went extinct
and it's important we bring them back
we're just selling them in cans
everyone's like what does it do just eat
[ __ ]
like a poop worm yeah i don't know
looks cool in a necklace
we're gonna bring in we're gonna have
josh richards bring the only woolly
mammoth up to the ship you know we're
bringing in a woolly mammoth
as a guest yeah
um then we're going to shoot it and
we're going to kill it the only ones and
we're going to we're going to kill it
live on set yep
you